eu employment and social affairs
ministers have adopted a recommendation
on a quality framework for traineeships
the aim is to ensure an efficient
education to work transition increasing
young people's employability
traineeships should offer quality
learning content and adequate working
conditions to best help people find jobs
this recommendation along with other
initiatives the initiatives for youth
employment
for the guarantee for the youth
system will contribute in integrating
the young
in our labor market ministers have also
agreed to a proposal on a social summit
for growth and employment
during policy debate on the 2014
european semester exercise ministers
adopted the conclusions that constitute
their contribution to the meeting of eu
leaders in march they also adopted a
report on employment and agreed on the
guidelines of employment policy
furthermore a regulation on the fund for
aid to the most deprived has been
adopted
over the next seven years member states
will have 3.5 billion euros to provide
material assistance to people in need or
to use in social inclusion projects